where does sushi trash come from I don't
know I think I was just looking for a
for a username and that was like a
username that wasn't taken I was like
sushi trash that was pretty crazy so I
went with that sub G Q I'm Josie and
these are my essentials it's just a
general like mood lifter sort of thing
I'm a cranky guy so it's probably
placebo but like at the same time like
it works so I'll take it you know
sometimes you wake up and you just know
it's gonna be a shitty day and then if
you know I'll grab for the wart pack I
should probably take one right now
actually now I'm gonna go move don't
worry I'm not good at swimming but I
hate running so like that's always
better at least you're like engulfed in
like a liquid I think I got them at Zara
or Bershka Berkshire or or one of those
places we keep my junk and everything
like properly like compacted during a
swim and they're like to carry around oh
no I think that's the best part that's
what I like about this there is no net
this might be TMI but the net can can
graze against things it hurts so fellas
don't get bored towards with netting
because that'll that'll make a lot of
parts ready
I always have one of these ready to go
it's the loud pack it's the honey
version though so I'm not a psychopath
it's got the honey [ __ ] on it like fruit
loops but like you're lying yourself a
little bit they're not horrible for you
so they just keep you going and it makes
me feel like a child again I think we
all had zip locks full of something
there's a little frame that I do carry
around with me all the time I put
different people in the frames we have
like this big inspiration to me I don't
know if you guys have heard of him his
name is blue face
he's a very lyrical robbery's he's very
OnPoint we've had we've had pump in the
frame Tom York believer you know all all
varieties this is just the juice box
hopefully I nail it there's this does
the Apple and there's the grape the
grape just feels like I'm ingesting way
more sugar same with strawberry I went
to the deli and I got a strawberry Fanta
and they're very syrupy like there's a
big difference between just the berry
Fantas and the more tropical ones it's
it's strange I know I'm boring you guys
I'm sorry these little Thomas the Tank
Engine candies is Japanese candy I like
it a lot I bring it around it's like
little little Thomas's that come out at
the Thomas you want to try some of these
no they're they're bad they're like it's
like if breath mints and chalk like I
had a baby but it was mostly chalk a
pads Pez yeah
that's where is yeah now it's starting
to look like I'm just put it on like a
healthy healthy look I swear it no I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to turn
my life around green superfoods it's
like one full serving of greens and
veggies you put in the in the water it
fizzes up and you just you don't have to
eat vegetables ever again I think that's
better than walking down broccoli I
actually wrap it in a shirt all the time
because I don't have a case for it but
this is actually the first real mic that
I ever bought when I was 16 and it's
just a USB mic so it kind of plugs right
into the computer I take it around
everywhere to to record and it's still
alive look at that on that lot of spit a
lot of disease on the blog tetanus and
sock on the mic works yeah I've done
sock on the mic but most of the time I
won't play anything on it like I'll just
like there's a lot of pop there's a nose
hair trimmer I actually grew out my nose
hairs like hoping that like I can I can
show you guys so the inside spins right
and then you just you hear it you hear
that [ __ ] being cut oh I can smell the
universe I see a lot of nose hairs out
there like let's be pretty again that's
essential I take around everywhere
because I've had fast growing nose hair
yeah yeah yeah me be careful with that I
just put on my nose when I was younger I
needed to grip something I blow my nose
in the morning or get a receipt and then
I go to school and then after school I'd
realized that I had whatever tissue
paper or receipt that I started on would
be compressed and crunched up in my hand
so I realized I needed to always like
hold something in my hand like so like
this just looks a little more socially
acceptable this is just a cool little
thing I found online I think it was like
residue of the fidget spinner movement
and like someone like was like trying to
like really milk it I appreciate it
though it's like you can just you know
go on for hours I can be quite a messy
eater so I have I always have a Hanes
singlet from Walgreens if it was like a
like a month-long tour probably go
through a healthy you know 20 20 to 30
maybe now if not nothing food like I'm
not I'm not eating that messy it's just
you know they get dirty you know they
get they get bloody
you know tough-guy [ __ ]
these are my headphones that I bring in
everywhere with me
a little tangled I don't like these
because they kind of like they don't fit
my ear shape so they like they'll fall
out like immediately if I had ear pods
that [ __ ] would like fall out like if
someone called my name
they'd all they just come knockin out
but these ones I can push them hard
enough into your ear you can be hear
them at good quality you know if they're
hitting a certain wall the only thing
people are gathering from this is that
like I'm just broke like thank you for
watching GQ these were my essentials the
things that I carry around I hope you
enjoyed I love you